all right on monday i told you
some states
are looking very strongly
at going in the direction
of considering
dropping mass mandates either indoor at
businesses and or
in schools over the last 48 hours since
i came to you with that report it is
accelerating dramatically more and more
localities more and more states talking
about no more masks as of some date in
the relatively near future could be
february could be march and the question
now is is this the right time not
everybody agrees that it is i don't
actually have an answer and so anybody
trying to read into whether i think it's
time to end masking or not i'm not
completely sure i think there's
definitely a discussion to be had let's
go through some of the news um uh wabc
reporting
indoor masking coming to an end in new
york
is it hocal or hotel i never remember
hokel expected to make an announcement
wednesday
it is anticipated that the governor of
new york will announce the end of the
indoor mass mandate in new york state on
wednesday but the city mandate will
remain in place
the state mandate requires mass to be
worn inside businesses where vaccination
status was not being checked it is set
to expire thursday and the new york
times reports that the governor will
rescind it
um
connecticut and new jersey are already
among a handful of states with plans to
ease mass mandates in schools the
governor of new york has not made the
same move
however she held a call with school
superintendents who believe an
announcement is coming soon
the governor is expected to extend the
mass mandate past its february 21st
expiration and through winter break
meanwhile
illinois is expected to announce an end
or rollback of certain mass rules cnn
reporting the governors of new york and
illinois are expected to announce the
end of or a plan to roll back
certain coveted mitigation requirements
involving masks today
i already told you about new york in
illinois governor jb pritzker will
likely announce wednesday a path for
ending the state's indoor mass mandate
in most public places
there is also increasingly pressure
in massachusetts on the governor charlie
baker to make some kind of uh off-ramp
type statement
many cities and towns already going in
that direction in california
california's indoor mask mandate will
end next week
for vaccinated people citing a 65
percent drop in coveted cases since the
peak of omicron california will end its
statewide indoor mass mandate for
vaccinated individuals next week
governor gavin newsom announced monday
on february 15 california's statewide
indoor mass requirement will expire
unvaccinated people must still wear
masks indoors less than 20 percent of
the state's population remain
unvaccinated according to data the biden
administration has not yet offered a
plan or roadmap for how to handle this
so a couple different things here number
one not everybody agrees about this one
example is the former surgeon general
jerome adams now jerome adams was not
exactly the voice of reason uh when the
donald trump was president so there are
people who would say
i don't care what jerome adams says but
jerome adams tweeting quote i
respectfully disagree with many of my
colleagues who are espousing the idea
that prematurely dropping mask mandates
will somehow make it easier to bring
them back if and when things get worse
again how'd that work out when cdc said
vaccinated could unmask last summer he
went on to say how do i define premature
well by looking at spread impact and
protection spread seven day average
still highest since april of last year
impact over 2500 deaths yesterday
protection only 22 percent of those 5 to
11 and 56 percent of 12 to 17 year olds
are vaccinated exit the highway early
trip takes longer
um i'm not sure if this is the right
thing to do or not on the one hand
jerome adams is right which is the
numbers are still not looking great
that being said
we know
that the numbers significantly lag what
is going on there are states with cases
down 85 to 90 percent
vaccines are so widely available
the death rate is so incredibly low for
the vaccinated that the there becomes a
question of what is the milestone
and if there is not a reversal if we say
well cases are down in the country about
70 percent
in some states they're down 85 to 90
percent if we give it one more month and
and that continues and there isn't a
reversal
there really won't be anything else to
wait for in the sense that it's not
going away
anytime soon there's going to be a low
level again if in the next month there's
not a new variant that causes cases to
spike in a month cases will be
really at what we might call an endemic
level doesn't mean that the cases are
mild it might or it might not but we're
talking about the case levels
there's a question of what would we be
waiting for at that point in time
um and there's not really a clear answer
and so that's where the if not in two to
four weeks then when
becomes a relevant question
um people who choose to remain
unvaccinated do so at their own risk and
as always the question then becomes what
about the immunocompromised
and um
that is a situation where those folks
say well i've gotten vaccinated
but
i still really can't do anything because
i might still catch it and i'm at higher
risk and that's a serious question i
mean a lot of those people haven't been
doing anything anyway so
it is a sort of chicken egg thing where
if the immuno-compromised folks that
have been staying home all this time
are already staying home
then
what is the reason to delay ending the
mask mandates for those who are not
staying home it's complicated i'm going
to admit that it's very complicated but
the question i keep coming back to is
if not in a month then what is the
milestone that we are waiting for and
i've not heard a good answer to that
which suggests
continuing on with some of this stuff
the school's question is a separate
question particularly when in schools
you've got a population that has a lower
vaccination rate
um
i'm thinking out loud along with you
guys and i know that in my audience
there are people who are saying
this is it it's time for the personal
responsibility phase end everything and
let people decide for themselves what
level of risk to accept like we do
during flu season some people already
would wear a mask during flu season or
stay home that's one side of my audience
the other side of my audience says do
nothing we need to keep masking for at
least the entire year
we should be closing schools we should
so so i know that there's different
sides in my audience and i'm curious to
hear from you find me on twitter at
dpakman and let me know what you think
should happen now